hi my name is Ronit Langer and I'm a
junior studying electrical engineering
and computer science and I'm really
interested at problems that exist at the
boundary of computer science and biology
one of the really pressing problems that
I'd like to address in my research is
the growing opioid crisis and the effect
that it's having on our first responders
when a first responder comes onto a
scene they're not sure what's in the air
and the problem is is that more powerful
opioids when they're aerosolized could
be potentially lethal and so what we
want to do is create a biological sensor
that's able to tell the first responders
whether or not those opioids are present
in the air the problem is is that the
current biological sensor we have
available to us is the natural MU opioid
receptor that lives in our brain but the
mute opioid receptor actually binds
promiscuously to all sorts of opioids
leading to the opioid crisis in the
first place and so what we want to do is
to take this mute opioid receptor and
mutate it in such a way that it binds
very specifically to powerful opioids
the problem is in protein engineering in
generals that we don't have a good
understanding of the relationship
between sequence structure and function
of a protein also the possible sequence
base that exists when you have 20 amino
acids is so much larger than the
observed amino acid space that we see in
nature and so what we want to do in this
project is to be able to take the mule
be ID receptor and mutate it in silico
meaning in on the computer and then
build it in vivo and tested in living
cells such that we can speed up this
process and create more powerful protein
sensors and so the way we do this is we
curate a large training set of very
similar proteins to the MU opioid
receptor and we test to see how
different mutations affect them in
living proteins and then we use that to
train a machine learning algorithm which
can then recommend better sequences for
us moving forward and then we go and we
test those sequences in cells and then
this process iterates until we get to
the desired functionality of our protein
and so once we've done this for the MU
opioid receptor we can take this
technology and extend it to many other
problems that exist in the protein
engineering space